[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
we're gonna make an appointment and see
what's going on
[Music]
um
all right potential looks awesome yeah
nice I joined the team in uh July I'm
the marketing manager of infinite
games.net very nice to meet you
um hey let me give you my card
the game has come a lot a long way even
in the month I mean the devs have been
working their tails off so and for my
understanding a very strong development
team very experienced what other
projects have they worked on um they
have worked on what it's more of what
happened what happened
um they worked on World of Warcraft they
worked on ESO they walked on uh at
Midway anything Midway they've been
involved Activision Blizzard okay
um xenomax so solid solid team very
excited about the potential of this man
for those who don't know just a quick
synopsis what is medical metalcore is a
a mechanized combat game the plan is 50
B 50.
[Music]
so you have the elements of PVP but you
also have the elements to be able to go
out and
complete missions complete quests that
will help to expand your neck and your
customization of the mech or your
character yourself also
um and if the plan is 50 B 50 here at
the booth this weekend we have 5v5 okay
um just a smaller that's what we got
setting up here this is
okay we'll be doing you know sessions of
10 people I think so so you're gonna do
five sessions of ten yep wow this is
really cool injury looks absolutely
phenomenal yes it's the Unreal Engine
which is what we're using to put the
game out on
my friends at Alienware gave us some 30
80s
so it's a it's an impressive now from
from this I've got a couple of
percussions yeah from the um inventory
what I'm saying like just the UI in
general now are the next individualized
or you the player customize your neck to
like respect you so we have light medium
and heavy necks along with light medium
and heavy infantry okay and that's a
super heavy infantry okay super heavy
infantry the gaming idea are like
walking tanks okay and then the uh right
there you'll see that's a medium
okay
so this this here this is what you're
capturing here is a domination match
style where you're holding points okay
also throughout the map are different
bunkers that you can hold as responses
and then go in to attack the center that
is awesome now here's the thing from a
capture standpoint tandemic it's
self-fest or you have to get out you
have to get out we're forcing the
engagement that's pretty cool
that is awesome really really good
yes
[Music]
uh
[Music]
further um
[Laughter]
well we have our um
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
your base arm your infantry armor your
max armor your health right and then and
a ball to the right what's that little
icon oh so they have different abilities
you have the ability
you guys heard it here first Middle
School
absolute outstanding looking in the room
thank you for the time brother this
looks really cool man let me get your
card yeah if you can because metal
medical I think our audience will be
very very interested
thank you so much
and you are again yes okay
beautiful
thank you guys you have an impressive
setup oh thank you I'm a content creator
as well thank you very much you
understand I have a lot of respect
appreciate you brother thank you so much
absolutely anytime you want to stop by
oh yeah oh we'll be back okay
you heard it here first man the Lords
are feeling it the Lords are free on it
I wanted to get that one in y'all whoa
[Music]
oh what's this oh wait a minute that's
Benedict
with them this is on Game Pass
this is uh something of Benedict I know
it help me out around here that last
case of Benedict Fox I remember this
game salute Rogue how you guys doing we
have an appointment but I just wanted to
showcase our audience great thank you
coming to Game Pass I believe as well
Benedict yes yeah yeah yeah this looks
extremely impressive can't wait to dive
deep with you guys love it man see I
think it's tomorrow we have it on
appointment impressive looking
impressive looking thank you